Emmental is a hard cheese made from cows
milk and it comes complete with holes
even though many non Swiss cheese makers
also use the name foremost Emmental is
the epitome of Swiss cheese
Marcus Agatha says it is even more these
occurs at the Saratoga break this cheese
has had an impact on our valley and it's
still the king of cheeses what makes
them entail so typical and unique is
that it tastes almost sweet amytal is a
valley in the canton of bern in west
central Switzerland some 100,000 people
live in the region which thrives mainly
on dairy farming
the river Emma gave its name to the
valley and locals are proud of a bridge
with Architecture from four centuries
not only Emmental cheese is made in the
region but with its unmistakable red
label genuine a mental is easy to
recognize
cheesemaker punished oily has to make
sure that the consistency is right he
can't lift the cheese himself because
it's so big those are the sites there
are historical reasons for that the
cheese used to be subject to customs
duties at the border and because each
wheel was taxed they were made as big as
possible about 100 kilograms these weigh
about 90 kilos which is a good size for
us in the production does the school
demas we then cut the cheese into small
rectangular blocks of 150 or 200 grams
same for malt and there if there is four
more
tourists can visit a special showcase
Darien amytal to find out exactly how
the famous cheese is made
it looks like a traditional farmhouse
the cheese are still made in the
traditional manner
like most today's visitors want to know
where the holes come from Emmental is
achieved with large holes that go
through two fermentation processes
lactic acid fermentation the breaking
down of lactose and propionic acid
fermentation which happens when
propionic acid bacteria are added this
only happens in Emmental and they
produce carbon dioxide that can't escape
and that's how these nice round holes
are created crossing load this is where
the cheese becomes firm it's then
pressed into a mold and stored in a
brine solution
the results go down well with the
visitors
okay save Visnjic abyss and she's has to
have a certain bite to it and the aroma
has to be a little bit pungent it can be
sous chef they open circuit very nice
the cheese is fantastic the temperature
is not too cold and it's stored for at
least a year or a year and a half that's
why the taste is more intensive knocketh
on Dom is their intensive limiters monk
it takes about an hour to cross the
region of Emmental from north to south
by car and a visit to this mountain
restaurant is always worthwhile
cheese finds its way into all the dishes
here
they're my mother's cordon bleu we use
it in our cordon bleu for quite a heavy
dish or we fill our ravioli with it for
something lighter with tomatoes and
olives tomato to buy or even with the
cows in Emmental produced generous
quantities of milk and without the milk
there would be no Emmental arguably the
king of cheese